backs in against brown pass deflected by
james johnson nice speed inside stanley
johnson gets it to go on another good
feed from horton tucker
eight points and paid attention to where
the trailing lebron james is coming from
also
meanwhile stanley johnson knocks down
the three
stanley johnson to drive feet inside
anthony with the finish
[Applause]
[Music]
lakers in lebron finds stanley johnson
who got the start tonight good bounce
underneath to avery who scores baseline
well they cut and they're very
willing to take them as the lakers turn
it over
nearly a travel
then wood good play coming back to
defend and stanley johnson nice hustle
christopher
into the lane so they have 40 paid
points tonight johnson going all the way
lays it up and in from collison's uh
shooting a better percentage from the
field than the lakers
what do we say at the beginning they can
score you can score
baseline stanley goes to the other side
and scores with the left hand sand goon
that time got faked we've got to get out
and run grizzlies in that first quarter
just two fast break points now grizzlies
shooting just 35 percent but as you guys
have talked about
always nice to have people check in on
twitter and say hey we're watching it
sweet
sharon has it knocked away stanley
johnson
lebron finds the open avery bradley
that one is tapped
long lead ahead of the pack is buchanan
and stanley johnson before he had him
tied up for a moment now it's jones from
the outside now lebron also had a
seven-game streak when he was with miami
in february of 2014.
stanley johnson drives and gets the
bounce
grizzy's best defensive rating is when
john conjar is on the floor and he had a
great road trip starting the last two
stanley johnson is in and hits the three
the 13th for the lakers tonight stanley
johnson making an impression especially
on the defensive end lebron for three
and he starts off the game with a trick
here portland one they had a huge first
quarter huge third quarter but damien
basically shot himself out of an early
season slumped at that game johnson from
lebron
shot rocks about 12 13 ahead of the game
clock
take a quick shot here and they try to
as lillard looks to split the defense
knocked out of bounds
lebron into the front court backing in
backing in on larry nance now falls back
wide open to stanley johnson in the
corner
stanley johnson and the finish by little
only had two points against utah but at
20 and 10 monday against dallas and
stanley johnson modern
you know he has been out with an illness
non-covered related for a couple of
games trevor deep and down
bring it up for a reason he's going to
get into the lane dry fit avery bradley
and the lakers do not get the bounce but
a nice offensive board by johnson
which means lebron's got the first
basket of the game
lebron averages just under seven assists
a game
bradley for three
you want to talk about consistency get
the block with no level ph
double figures going seven and last ten
before they leave it right for stanley
johnson he goes all the way and gets
fouled
[Applause]
we've certainly been playing at an mvp
level
the last couple of weeks what an effort
by stanley johnson yeah and that's his
middle name and it effort when i asked
coach vogel for an update on a.d he said
the organization would not be giving an
update
on and malik month there for the nice
shot there
great start for bradley carmelo anthony
into the game
collins had it blocked by johnson
[Music]
bunk up to 24.
johnson with the anticipation and the
steal fouled counted
off of the stellar defense stanley
johnson active hands about this finish
takes it to the body of capella before
he was able to play for them he had to
go into health and safety protocols
and then got another call up
subsequently from the lakers
and had a big game on christmas day on
abc
against brooklyn they're a different
team when they do that young tried to
lop it up for capella never made it
there
and here's james again leading the break
dimes it inside to westbrook and he tips
it in himself lebron had that huge
fourth quarter in the win the other
night over atlanta stanley johnson just
inside the free throw line and we're two
to nothing like
just that
there he is underneath trying to get it
to tillman
they threw it away and tillman's gonna
foul stanley johnson lebron doubled up
baseline good little cut by bradley now
finds stanley johnson did not start but
came in for ariza after 90 seconds and
he's got his first bucket boy he's
having some fun over the last month or
so he just wants his team to win
more games
lakers once again hovering around that
500 mark they've been there all year
stanley hits a three yes
stanley
couldn't quite get a handle on it and
he'll launch a three knock it down
stanley johnson stanley johnson is
perfect from the field he's three for
three getting into what they want to on
this time down the floor
everything about 30 feet away from the
basket so monk just says i'll take it
well he's only missed a couple of shots
in the game
eight rebounds
now stanley johnson's got the layup
[Applause]
turned his back right there on the ball
they went right by his ear yeah he got
capped on that one
set up pretty good by
malik
but donovan's taken away by stanley
johnson that's why he's on this team
tonight here in the first quarter just
under three minutes to play i hope
you're enjoying it so far on spectrum
sportsnet
this is the first of a brief two-game
home stand johnson in the middle got it
bring it up for stanley finally made the
all-star team
clarkson trying to attack rob looking
for gobert and hit the rim and go to
high enough
a couple of points in the early going
rings all the way to score
a little bit of injury
to that
second and pull-up jumpers in the nba
from three
[Applause]
knocking down the long ball remember at
the beginning of the year it was the
dreaded third quarter for the lakers
they got significantly better they don't
want to fall back into their old habits
reverse left after a great bounce by
stanley johnson a t-h-t
fake like he was going to come up the
top and then goes back door straight
baseline cut
and what a pass
to foul the basket
typical stanley with nine seconds at
that time
especially with lebron handling it with
five with four down the middle goes
johnson he puts it up and then wow with
2.3 remaining rudy gave us one out of
eight for three mitchell mixes from
three mitchell is over six from three
stanley johnson runs in to go bare he'll
get a three-point opportunity
the shot blockers you can't show the
ball and you can't give him any space
get contact play it up late in
i mean
you know denver could miss denver could
miss they're having trouble making
stanley though for he's asserting
himself here in the full seven minutes
to play
craig was having an embarrassing loss in
denver
battling utah stands down again
johnson from the free-throw line makers
are back up to 44
stanley johnson
high school
finds his way back to southern
california raises it again
just takes it off the drip uses the left
lays it in and gives the lakers a four
point lead his first
field goal of the game that's crazy
that's the recipe for disaster if you're
utah johnson underneath scores again and
he beat rudy goldberg in the restricted
area against goldberg and get him to
back off enough and then just steps
through and sports got bob donovan
to shoot over by donovan
rebounds johnson toes the line and gives
the lakers an extra 14.
stanley controls finds bradley
yes
yes sir taking a little exception to
that
that was just a great play by stanley
johnson offensive rebound
then he gets the pass back from lebron
and spots the man opening the corner and
gets the assist to avery brown
1916's after the hot start and the
lakers up by eighth oh good moving and a
nice dish monk to stanley they've been
outscored 24-12 since the three-minute
mark of the second quarter
good shovel pass to bradley stanley
johnson with the game
horton tucker well he started out on
fire tonight
stanley took it
mj had seven straight games of 25 plus
puts it in nice perspective here's
terence ross that's going to be a
turnover stanley comes in and makes sure
he doesn't get the shot away
jalen horton tucker
put okiki on him
they're gonna leave it for stanley
johnson gonna try a three and knock it
down yes sir for stanley johnson
lakers taking on the steal shovel pass
to stanley johnson wide open is lebron
one bounce drifts left and it's three
for the king nearly stepping over back
did he do yeah very close
spinning russ russ in trouble but he
finds stanley who hits the three
after that surgery and missing 30 games
has yet to really find his footing
jalen suggs he turns it over
up to lebron here he goes all the way to
score
russ all the way drive kick stanley got
it
stanley johnson and it's a
71-64 laker lead what a what a way to
come out of the locker room so robinson
fires sure
this is stanley johnson on a 10-day
contract for the lakers former lottery
ticket and he murders all the way in for
the score
[Music]
[Applause]
see martin coming over to help out it
comes stanley jackson and he makes it
stanley johnson excuse me with under
four minutes to go on the first
lebron james getting a rest high low
action johnson the catch
the layup is good cam thomas left his
feet and johnson leans forward for the
rebound monk taps it over to horton
tucker 12 point cushion for la
johnson aggressive gets the roll
league sources have informed me that in
order for him to make a full recovery
and a hope that they can get a potential
deep playoff run going durant is
expected to sit out the all-star game in
cleveland next month
[Applause]
pass is high hardin bounces it johnson
devours it turnover james to the rim